my guest tonight has stirred in numerous
films including anchorman talladega
nights and
elf just to name three out of seven
thousand
his latest movies really funny
eurovision song contest
the story of fire saga and it's
currently streaming on
netflix please welcome my enemy
will ferrell how are you will
that there's no no one's applauding will
there's no audience
no will no there's no
they're so used to doing that uh
for talk show appearances that it's hard
to break that habit
yeah do you miss the laughter in
quarantine
oh my god you know what i've trained
my children to act like a room full of
sitcom writers
that everything i say they just go
[Laughter]
yeah but the weird thing is they're now
saying things like
i wrote that wrote that line
[Laughter]
i wrote that that's mine that's mine
uh-huh
i want to say you um you look very
handsome i like your hair and quarantine
you look good your hair is getting it's
a nice uh
very puffy your hair i didn't realize
yeah i can get
i can get a lot of volume very quickly
if it's not maintained um
and uh i don't know
there's no reason to cut it yeah
no these are strange times to say the
least do you have anyone in your family
that you would trust with cutting your
hair
here's the thing no i would not trust
anyone to cut my hair
but uh i kind of like just letting it go
you know the conan pompadour sure
classic classic classic thanks
uh it has collapsed under the weight of
the length of the hair
and now i'm just letting it go you're
almost unrecognizable
yeah do you like without the pump yeah
can you hear a truck backing up in the
background
nope oh then i probably shouldn't have
called attention to it
it's incredibly loud here at the theater
we're shooting at the largo theater i
know you've appeared here many times
i am having a whole truckload of omaha
steaks though delivered to you and your
crew
[Laughter]
maybe that that may be the truck why did
you have them delivered
when you knew we'd be interviewed that
seems awkward
you know what i didn't remember exactly
i just said you know they have those
windows they said anytime from one to
four
so is that up to me
no no i uh are you doing okay i like is
that your office right there that looks
like the office that
that a manager would have at a
construction site what's happening here
it really does look like
it's funny you should say that i am in
one of those mini trailers that you'd
see on a construction site
uh-huh that's what it looked like yeah
with no windows
and just a weird door and bad uh wood
paneling
uh-huh yeah this is a little a little uh
little offshoot
yeah a little office here yeah would you
tell me would you be honest with me
if during this period of time you were
working at a construction oh what's that
oh network that's a great movie i still
gotta watch network so that's on
my to-do list
that's that's why you have you had a
you had a small trailer built on your
property so you could watch the movie
network
network and uh what else
we got here oh a bootleg of a face in
the crowd
okay listen to me listen to me there's
something
will i got a lot of bootlegs
there's something called streaming you
could stream all of this
no no no no no no
i like the old-fashioned dvd okay well
i think that's a good use of your time
to be in a small shack
watching old movies in an outmoded
format
and i congratulate you i also want to
congratulate you
on the movie eurovision song contest
uh the story of fire saga i watched this
last night
another enjoyable romp i i have to tell
you i really enjoyed it but i didn't
know anything about
eurovision yeah the eurovision song
contest is a real thing
that you've been obsessed with for a
while is that right yes it is a
uh it's been going on for 60 plus years
uh and every year it's watched
from anywhere to 180 to 200 million
people
uh and it is one of the craziest things
you'll ever see i i discovered it
literally 20 years ago
with my wife we were visiting her uh
family in sweden and uh
we we had dinner and all of a sudden her
cousin was like uh
so shall we uh watch and uh
i was like okay yeah what's that and and
sat there for
three hours mesmerized by
i had no idea what was going on uh but
it is
it is like cirque du soleil means
american idol meets i don't know
a a a residency show in vegas it's it's
uh it's the craziest thing you've ever
seen also
meets the olympics because it's
different countries
going up against each other and one of
the things you
capture in this movie is there is
something about
european entertainment and that is
uh very specific
and so you in the movie you portray
people
singing uh like rock power ballads
dressed as
vikings that's something that really
could happen on eurovision
a hundred percent and it's it's so
foreign to us
as americans you know we any sort of our
competitive
music shows we're we're pretty much into
looking as cool as we can uh in
eurovision
it's quite the opposite even though they
fully believe they're looking as cool as
possible uh but yeah you'll you'll see
everything from costumes a lot of
pyrotechnics
a lot of people uh just on stage
doing nothing that has anything to do
with the song
including one of the i i've actually
been to three of them in person and one
of the bits that we actually lifted and
put in the movie was
um i think i believe it was the ukraine
and this
this singer was was singing
but behind them on the stage was a man
just running
in a life human-sized hamster wheel
for three minutes and was never
referenced in any way
and uh i had nothing to do with the song
nothing to
the song the singer didn't look back the
the the they even got a tight shot of
the guy running in the hamster wheel he
just kept running
he wouldn't even look at the camera
[Music]
and we were obsessed with that image
that we we ended up putting it in the
movie
you know what i love is that you're in
the hamster wheel yeah
full out but unlike uh
the example you just gave you also have
to sing
while you're running full out in the
hamster wheel
which looks hilarious and i imagine was
next to impossible
well it is one of those moments where
and i found myself
on numerous occasions over my career
when i read something on the page i
forget that i'm actually going to have
to do it
[Laughter]
and there i was on that day
being hoisted about 50 feet above the
ground
in a hamster wheel that i kind of had to
control with my own
gate and then singing the lyrics uh uh
but
you know we got it done you got it done
yeah you got it done in style
but the uh the prop master did remind me
on several occasions how difficult it
was to build that hamster wheel
i was like okay but isn't that your job
yeah but i'm just telling you there's
97 there's 96 well joints alone
on that piece of steel all right
okay thank you yeah thank you i think he
was looking for a big thank you
thank you i i said thank you said thank
you more
i should have sent him omaha steaks um
you uh you revealed that you have
quite a nice singing voice will and i it
leads me to wonder
what about you putting out an album will
ferrell sings
is that something that could happen uh
you know it could you never know
uh but i would probably be drawn to more
of a spoken word album i'd love to bring
back spoken word
i mean just saying the lyrics saying the
lyrics
not actually singing the song nope and
not like eight or ten songs 30 to 50
songs spoken word
that's gonna be a very very long album
you're gonna you're gonna want to sit
back
and really really be able to dedicate a
nice chunk of time to it yeah
i think you're going to want to listen
to it as you drive from la to boston
then and you're going to maybe just get
through all the songs
maybe as you get to framingham mass
exactly in fact i'm gonna that's how i'm
gonna do a dry run
where i time it so that when you pull
into framingham
you finish the album okay this sounds
like a
awful idea thank you you've given me a
great idea
no don't do today don't do it
it's about it no got it
no you're there's a scene in the movie
you know i
no no don't don't make your spoken word
album no
no salute no no one has ever saluted
thank you conan such a bad idea
there's a scene in the movie where you
um you wear a leotard
and a lot of actors get very
self-conscious about their bodies
beforehand i will hazard to guess you do
not
is that fair to say uh
not only do i not uh but
that the sad part of of the scene you're
talking about
is um i was
i was looking really skinny for me uh
that period of time and uh
in fact i had dropped about 10 to 15
pounds
okay uh but
you know what i it just doesn't still
doesn't work
yeah well this is you at a a low weight
for you me in pretty darn good shape
[Laughter]
did you walk around like check this out
because here here's where we are now
okay okay
there's okay yeah there's um
so thank you for that
thank you let's did you get a good shot
of that
guys guys in the booth yeah every yeah
there's no booth here
it's just a zoom but yes we we saw all
of that and
um it was fantastic have you put on
uh uh uh some weight during this period
of time i find it extremely hard to uh
yes i have put on uh some weight
yeah i've kept the weight out of my face
no you still look yeah but good lines
yeah i have
a way of getting fat out of my face
which i do at home
oh using a rubber tube uh and a suction
device
and uh a sterilized razor blade that
keeps me
looking it keeps it cheap but i'm a
bloated monster
i would say from mid-chest down yeah yep
uh a bloated parody of a human being oh
yeah anyway yeah
um you look like you're about to cry so
i was going to give you a moment what
what are you going to do
you know what i really like i really
like that your father in this film is
portrayed by pierce brosnan
it takes some serious balls
to cast the handsomest man in the world
as your father
right a total dick move
it literally makes no sense
[Laughter]
and he's very funny he's very funny
he's so funny and uh you know he
he he is like one of those people who's
kind of a you know like a perfect human
being like an o you know the ultimate
dinner party guests uh so gracious and
kind and humorous stories and
uh there is a scene in the movie where
he kind of gives me a
i've kind of given up my dream and i'm
going to just follow in his footsteps
he's a fisherman
our family has been a long line of
fishermen and i've
we're on the boat and he kind of gives
me this speech to to you know go back
and
and and go back to the contest and uh
and do what i was you know put on earth
to do well the day we happened to be
filming
i i don't it was it was just we had to
film on that day
and there were five to six foot swells
and we were
literally shooting on this boat and
people were getting sick and not hiding
it and uh
and there's pierce just first of all
looking so dashing
in a fisherman's outfit i don't know how
you do that number one right
uh number two not seasick at all just
in between takes while crew people are
throwing up violently
on the side of the boat and there he is
just taking selfies and
his aviator sunglasses just looking
perfect yeah
um we finally got to to to the to the
dock
after he came off the boat and he was
like that
was a day
so i i think that was a positive
statement well we have a clip here
from uh eurovision song contest the
story
of fire uh saga
i don't know what the what's which i
believe this is uh
this is uh rachel mcadams who plays
secret
uh uh my bandmate uh this is
this is before us getting ready to go on
stage
for the icelandic singing contest this
is to
the chance to represent iceland right in
eurovision
this is like the semi semifinals just my
finals and this is our backstage prep
okay let's take a look at this clip from
eurovision song contest the story
of fire saga i am so nervous lars
i wish i could sing in icelandic i know
it would calm me secrets
you know that a song in icelandic would
never win the eurovision song
i know i know i'm being silly but i'm
just i'm just anxious
it's really a dream come true
yes no i know
oh what are you doing uh
i just want my ding-dong to look bigger
than what is really there
smart should i draw attention to my
groin area as well no you get it yeah i
could do a camo
do a classic camel okay it's never out
of style that looks good
pretty good huh and we're back
wasn't that pretty cool pretty cool
and i hope that was the right setup
uh if not we can uh
[Laughter]
i think given under the circumstances
i'm in an abandoned theater
you're clearly managing a construction
site um
i think we're doing pretty well all
things considered
i gotta have a crane by tuesday
we've already talked about this
conan these guys are there yeah it's a
really good thing you're there
and i did want to thank you you're doing
something very cool which is i've seen
some paparazzi shots of you
i saw one where you're wearing a t-shirt
and the message on the t-shirt says
thank you frontline workers
you're using your celebrity
uh to and the fact that there are
paparazzi to get out this great message
which i thought was a very clever thing
to do
yeah we've had a number of shirts that
we've gotten we've got uh
teachers aren't paid enough uh thank you
frontline workers
uh uh doctor and dr fauci we trust
so it's been a fun way to kind of
yeah no i have to say your shirts are
probably more noble than mine
my shirts have been let's make this
about me
uh check out my show 11 tbs um
and i'd like to see more evidence that
this uh kovid really exists
i i saw your one shirt that says if i'm
going to die at least let me be drunk
conan come on you don't need to go to
the bars
all the time well those were the shirts
i owned
before kovid and i have to that was free
those are a pre-code
yeah i had a shirt that said hey man
masks aren't my thing i've had that for
years
i remember you wearing that at the back
at nbc
yeah yeah yeah i was anti-mask
way back then so um you're a good man
i think we've been interviewing uh i've
been interviewing you for i think it's
65 years now right
we started in the old ed sullivan
theater
and uh no i was never in the ed sullivan
you're thinking of david letterman
some great great moments stupid pet
tricks
all of it so great and that was that was
david letterman
you're confusing me i've wonderful times
i i thought we were close
i've interviewed you hundreds of times
your canadian band leader no that's most
faith
classes no not
so so let me thank you
you're thinking wait were you thinking
me or no no no no
i wasn't even thanking you i was
irritated
am i getting an award you're not getting
an award
okay you're terrible i think you're a
terrible person
i'm a terrible listener
[Laughter]
hey will it is just uh always a joy to
talk to
you're one of my uh favorite people of
all time i said one of
yeah i know i know a little wiggle room
i know
you know i'm not gonna nope i know vivit
uh you're one of my favorite people i
want to make sure i get the word out
eurovision song contest the story of
fire saga
is available now on netflix and look for
will
spoken word album that will be about
18 hours long i believe coming out
sometime in the future
it's gonna be great no great awful
uh conan thanks pal stay safe and uh
we'll jam at fargo one of these days
uh you didn't mean that and you'll
forget who i am shortly after you sign
off seriously
honey a cement mixer
how what what's the confusion
[Laughter]
mixer you know what i don't usually it's
hard to build a bridge
i'm just going to do that i don't know
i'm usually doing single family homes
but we got hired by the city to build a
bridge
and uh i don't think you're qualified to
be taking on the project
trust me i know it but don't tell the
city that
uh hey will seriously uh that was great
but it's nice to see you
uh you look good you look good yeah
thanks and i look good too
you look like the way you always do
okay so nice
will all right take it easy well thank
you bye